Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This paper is about interactively modeling
and editing climbing plants.
This is one of my favorite kind of works:
mundane sounding topic, immaculate execution.
There are so many cool things about this paper,
I don't even know where to start.
But first, let's let's talk about the modeling
part.
We can, for instance, plant a seed, and we
can not only have a look at how it grows as
time goes by, but we can also influence the
grow variability and shoot growth rates.
Branches can be added and removed at will
at any point in time.
We can also add attractors, regions that are
set to be more likely for the plant to grow
towards.
With these techniques, we can easily create
any sort of artistic effect, be it highly
artificial looking vines and branches, or
some long forgotten object overgrown with
climbing plants.
However, a model is just 3d geometry.
What truly makes these models come alive is
animation, which is also executed with flying
colors.
The animations created with this technique
are both biologically and physically plausible.
So what do these terms mean exactly?
Biologically plausible means that the plants
grow according to the laws of nature, and
physically plausible means that if we start
tugging at it, branches start moving, bending
and breaking according to the laws of physics.
Due to its responsive and interactive nature,
the applications of this technique are typically
in the domain of architectural visualization,
digital storytelling, or any sort of real-time
application.
And of course, the usual suspects, animated
movies and game developers can use this to
create more immersive digital environments
with ease.
And don't forget about me, Károly, who would
happily play with this basically all day long.
If you are one of our many Fellow Scholars
who are completely addicted to Two Minute
Papers, make sure to check out our Patreon
page where you can grab cool perks, like watching
these episodes in early access, or deciding
the order of upcoming episodes, and more.
Also, your support is extremely helpful, so
much so, that even the price of a cup of coffee
per month helps us to create better videos
for you.
We write some reports from time to time to
assess the improvements we were able to make
with your support.
The link is in the video description, or you
can just click the letter P on the ending
screen in a moment.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!